we are one week away from the critical
midterm elections with the future of
Congress at stake Republicans now
control both the house in the Senate
Democrats hold 195 House seats they
would need a net gain of 23 seats on
election day to take control of the
House of Representatives in the Senate
Republicans have a two-seat majority but
most of the 35 seats being contested are
held by Democrats tight races are
unfolding in several states including
Arizona Missouri and Florida where
Democrat Democratic Senator Bill Nelson
is neck and neck in his reelection
battle with Republican Governor Rick
Scott Democrat Andrew Gilliam and
Republican Ron De Santis are also locked
in a tight and increasingly contentious
race to replace Scott as governor Nancy
Cordes is in Miami covering the state's
midterm battle Nancy good morning good
morning those races you mentioned are so
close here that President Trump is
scheduled to campaign here in Florida
twice between now and Election Day
once tomorrow once over the weekend and
former President Obama is scheduled to
come here as well as early voting is
already on track to break records we
ready to flip florida blue florida's
governor's race pits the mayor of
Tallahassee against a Republican
congressman from Jacksonville
taking a page from the president
Republican Ron de santis hammered his
opponent on immigration in these closing
weeks we don't want open borders in
Florida we don't want to abolish race in
Florida they are just way out of step
with the people this state Democrat
Andrew Gilliam has focused on health
care we deserve to expand Medicaid and
offer access to health care for over
800,000 of the most medically needy
people in our state three-term Senator
Bill Nelson is hoping a strong showing
from Gilliam at the top of the ticket
will help him fend off a challenge from
Governor Rick Scott Rick Scott for eight
years has refused to expand Medicaid
Medicaid was a rare topic of agreement
among the four Florida voters we met in
Miami
Wanda should Florida have expanded
Medicaid I think so I think it should
have you know we talked about taking
care of our citizens and one of the most
important ways can do that is to ensure
the health of our citizens but they were
divided over immigration and that
caravan of Honduran migrants heading
north there are people that are fleeing
immense persecution they're fleeing
poverty they're think they're fleeing
hunger and they want to come to United
States so you're saying that they should
then go ahead break the immigration laws
come here and take over and come before
the people that are waiting on it mr.
kair Vince like a thousand miles away I
think it's just being used as a as a
midterm election to issue to rile up the
base
we all came all of our ancestors came
here from somewhere you know I mean but
they all came legally yes legally in an
appropriate manner the president waded
into the governor's race here yesterday
tweeting that the Democratic candidate
Andrew Gilliam without proof is a thief
Gilliam responded on Twitter calling the
president weak and urging Floridians to
vote Norah some people calling that
racially charged language Nancy thank
you